This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及构建抗逆力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听TWO percent。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论20世纪80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.|||在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？您正在收听由您最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在AHA radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.|||2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and trends. transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners,
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and trends. transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners,|||我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和趋势、转型及其对我们心理学意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听众，
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you for joining us for another episode. This week, we're talking about open relationships, a very hot topic at the moment amongst 20-something-year-olds and others alike. And it has been frequently requested that we investigate the psychology behind this non-monogamous arrangement. So that's what we're going to do today from the very basics of what they actually entail, the boundaries, the dynamics, and why they are seemingly becoming increasingly popular amongst this generation. Before we get into it, a brief disclaimer that all consenting romantic relationships are respected and accepted here. If open relationships are your thing or you're exploring the idea or completely opposed and just here
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you for joining us for another episode. This week, we're talking about open relationships, a very hot topic at the moment amongst 20-something-year-olds and others alike. And it has been frequently requested that we investigate the psychology behind this non-monogamous arrangement. So that's what we're going to do today from the very basics of what they actually entail, the boundaries, the dynamics, and why they are seemingly becoming increasingly popular amongst this generation. Before we get into it, a brief disclaimer that all consenting romantic relationships are respected and accepted here. If open relationships are your thing or you're exploring the idea or completely opposed and just here|||老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。感谢您收听我们的又一期节目。本周，我们讨论的是开放式关系，这是目前二十多岁年轻人和其他群体中非常热门的话题。并且经常有人要求我们调查这种非一夫一妻制安排背后的心理学。所以这就是我们今天要做的，从它们实际包含的内容、界限、动态，以及为什么它们在这个世代中似乎越来越受欢迎的基础知识开始。在我们开始之前，作一个简短的免责声明：这里尊重并接受所有情投意合的恋爱关系。如果开放式关系是你的菜，或者你正在探索这个想法，或者完全反对，只是来这里
to learn. I just hope that this is informative. We are not here to judge. There is none of that. And whilst I'm not personally excited by the idea of being in an open relationship myself, I do find them fascinating, especially as a concept to be explored through a psychological lens because whilst I know I'm not a fan, some people are. Some people are. Some people are big proponents. So what makes us different in that desire for this type of relationship? I think psychology has a lot to do with it and no romantic relationship is a one size fits all kind of deal. Open relationships are just part of this broader ecosystem of what's possible and what works for you. So open relationships, polyamory, ethical non-monogamy, they all seem to be a
to learn. I just hope that this is informative. We are not here to judge. There is none of that. And whilst I'm not personally excited by the idea of being in an open relationship myself, I do find them fascinating, especially as a concept to be explored through a psychological lens because whilst I know I'm not a fan, some people are. Some people are. Some people are big proponents. So what makes us different in that desire for this type of relationship? I think psychology has a lot to do with it and no romantic relationship is a one size fits all kind of deal. Open relationships are just part of this broader ecosystem of what's possible and what works for you. So open relationships, polyamory, ethical non-monogamy, they all seem to be a|||学习。我只希望这能提供有价值的信息。我们不是来评判的。没有那种事。虽然我个人对身处开放式关系这个想法并不感到兴奋，但我确实觉得它们很迷人，特别是作为一个通过心理学视角去探索的概念，因为虽然我知道我不是粉丝，但有些人是。有些人是。有些人是坚定的支持者。那么，是什么让我们在对这种关系的渴望上有所不同呢？我认为心理学在其中起着很大的作用，而且没有任何一种恋爱关系是千篇一律的。开放式关系只是可能性和适合你的事物的更广阔生态系统的一部分。所以开放式关系、多边恋、道德非一夫一妻制，它们似乎都属于
a trend and I've personally noticed them becoming a lot more common amongst people in their 20s, especially amongst people that I know personally and couples that I know. And also a lot of people that I encounter on dating apps or in my real life who talk about their desire for ethical non-monogamy or who are in an open relationship looking for a third, I guess, or someone else to join. Maybe that is a similar experience for you. and I think it's because of a broader societal shift away from conventional ideas of marriage and monogamy and tradition towards greater sexual liberation and experiences.
a trend and I've personally noticed them becoming a lot more common among people in their 20s, especially among people that I know personally and couples that I know. And also a lot of people that I encounter on dating apps or in my real life who talk about their desire for ethical non-monogamy or who are in an open relationship looking for a third, I guess, or someone else to join. Maybe that is a similar experience for you. and I think it's because of a broader societal shift away from conventional ideas of marriage and monogamy and tradition towards greater sexual liberation and experiences.|||一种趋势，我个人注意到它们在二十多岁的人群中变得越来越普遍，尤其是在我个人认识的人和我认识的情侣当中。还有我在约会软件上或现实生活中遇到的很多人，他们谈论自己对道德非一夫一妻制的渴望，或者处于开放式关系中，我想是在寻找第三者或其他加入的人。也许你也有类似的经历。我认为这是因为更广泛的社会转变，人们正在抛弃关于婚姻、一夫一妻制和传统的传统观念，转向更大的性解放和体验。
Although they have become more popular in recent decades, this idea of an open relationship isn't a new one. It's existed since ancient societies in Greece and Rome, China, Mongolia, Japan, but the term that we use now, open relationship, it was only first coined and popularized in the 1970s. Since then, some studies have suggested that up to 6% of relationships and partnerships could be deemed as non-monogamous or open, which is not the same as cheating or infidelity, but a consensual willingness to explore romantic and sexual connections, beyond the core partnership. It's this idea of being in a long-term relationship, marriage or
Although they have become more popular in recent decades, this idea of an open relationship isn't a new one. It's existed since ancient societies in Greece and Rome, China, Mongolia, Japan, but the term that we use now, open relationship, it was only first coined and popularized in the 1970s. Since then, some studies have suggested that up to 6% of relationships and partnerships could be deemed as non-monogamous or open, which is not the same as cheating or infidelity, but a consensual willingness to explore romantic and sexual connections, beyond the core partnership. It's this idea of being in a long-term relationship, marriage or|||尽管近几十年来它们变得越来越受欢迎，但开放式关系这个概念并不是什么新概念。它自古希腊、罗马、中国、蒙古、日本等古代社会起就存在了，但我们现在使用的这个术语——开放式关系，直到20世纪70年代才首次被创造并普及。从那时起，一些研究表明，高达6%的恋爱和伴侣关系可以被视为非一夫一妻制或开放式关系，这与出轨或不忠不同，而是一种在核心伴侣关系之外，出于自愿探索浪漫和性连接的意愿。这就是处于长期关系中的想法，无论是婚姻还是
otherwise, but still being able to date other people and of course, sleep with other people beyond the bounds of each other. I think that they are typically less focused on emotional connections and more on sexual ones, which either partner or both feels that they need. And for some, they really work. They keep the relationship the bond and the trust between two people exceptionally strong. And in a generation where up to 30% of people in married partnerships admit to infidelity, maybe consensual non-monogamy is the secret to making long-term relationships more sustainable by letting people in.
otherwise, but still being able to date other people and of course, sleep with other people beyond the bounds of each other. I think that they are typically less focused on emotional connections and more on sexual ones, which either partner or both feels that needs. And for some, they really work. They keep the relationship the bond and the trust between two people exceptionally strong. And in a generation where up to 30% of people in married partnerships admit to infidelity, maybe consensual non-monogamy is the secret to making long-term relationships more sustainable by letting people in.|||其他形式，但仍然能够与其他人约会，当然，也可以在彼此的界限之外与其他人发生性关系。我认为它们通常较少关注情感连接，而更多地关注性连接，这是任何一方或双方觉得需要的。对某些人来说，它们确实管用。它们使两个人之间的关系、纽带和信任异常牢固。在一个已婚伴侣中有多达30%的人承认不忠的世代，也许知情同意的非一夫一妻制是通过接纳他人使长期关系更具可持续性的秘诀。
It might be an alien idea for some, but we are going to explore it today. So what is the deal with open relationships? And more importantly, what is the psychology behind the desire to pursue one and the attraction of this relationship model, particularly in our 20s? Non-monogamy, I think, naturally goes against a lot of our traditional beliefs about relationships and marriage in particular. But some people need different things from their relationships to be fulfilled. and I do think open relationships are quite misunderstood. So we are going to explore exactly what draws people into open relationships from personality to attributes like sociosexuality,
It might be an alien idea for some, but we are going to explore it today. So what is the deal with open relationships? And more importantly, what is the psychology behind the desire to pursue one and the attraction of this relationship model, particularly in our 20s? Non-monogamy, I think, naturally goes against a lot of our traditional beliefs about relationships and marriage in particular. But some people need different things from their relationships to be fulfilled. and I do think open relationships are quite misunderstood. So we are going to explore exactly what draws people into open relationships from personality to attributes like sociosexuality,|||对某些人来说，这可能是一个陌生的概念，但我们今天要探讨它。那么，开放式关系到底是怎么回事呢？更重要的是，追求这种关系的渴望背后的心理学是什么，以及这种关系模型的吸引力在哪里，特别是在我们的20多岁时？我认为，非一夫一妻制自然违背了我们关于关系、特别是婚姻的许多传统信仰。但有些人需要从他们的关系中获得不同的东西来获得满足。而且我确实认为开放式关系被严重误解了。因此，我们将探讨究竟是什么吸引人们进入开放式关系，从性格到社会性等属性，
why the choice seems right for some people, what is required to make them work, and the interactions between jealousy and attachment style, but also what it means to be the other person, the casual partner, the outsider, of one or more members of, the primary relationship. So I am so excited and ready to get into it.
why the choice seems right for some people, what is required to make them work, and the interactions between jealousy and attachment style, but also what it means to be the other person, the casual partner, the outsider, of one or more members of, the primary relationship. So I am so excited and ready to get into it.|||为什么这个选择对某些人来说是正确的，让它们发挥作用需要什么条件，以及嫉妒与依恋风格之间的相互作用，还有成为主要关系中一个或多个成员的“第三者”、随意的伴侣、局外人意味着什么。所以我非常兴奋，准备深入探讨。
Without further ado, let's break down the psychology of open relationships in our 20s. The concept of an open relationship may be hard to grasp for some people, especially in a society that has repeatedly pushed monogamy on us since birth, but there is actually a rising interest in this way of living and dating. Now more than ever I think in modern society, a lot of couples are exploring alternatives, having conversations about it, and even committing to an open relationship or polyamory or some form of non-monogamy. In the past, I think societal norms and pressures have made this type of relationship seem wrong or really strange or off limits and stigmatized, which I think is where a lot of our natural ickyness comes from, especially because of traditional
Without further ado, let's break down the psychology of open relationships in our 20s. The concept of an open relationship may be hard to grasp for some people, especially in a society that has repeatedly pushed monogamy on us since birth, but there is actually a rising interest in this way of living and dating. Now more than ever I think in modern society, a lot of couples are exploring alternatives, having conversations about it, and even committing to an open relationship or polyamory or some form of non-monogamy. In the past, I think societal norms and pressures have made this type of relationship seem wrong or really strange or off limits and stigmatized, which I think is where a lot of our natural ickyness comes from, especially because of traditional|||闲话少说，让我们来剖析二十多岁时开放式关系的心理学。开放式关系的概念对某些人来说可能很难理解，特别是在一个自出生起就不断向我们灌输一夫一妻制的社会中，但实际上人们对这种生活和约会方式的兴趣正在上升。我认为在现代社会，比以往任何时候都多，许多情侣正在探索替代方案，就此进行对话，甚至致力于开放式关系、多边恋或某种形式的非一夫一妻制。过去，我认为社会规范和压力使这种类型的关系看起来是错误的、真的很奇怪、或是禁区并被污名化，我认为这就是我们许多天然的排斥感的来源，特别是因为传统的
beliefs about monogamy that arose from very Puritan religious influences. However, many people have pointed to the new age theory that monogamy is a socially rather than naturally biologically constructed idea. And with access to things like the internet and books and even influences, individuals are showing a very big interest nowadays. We also have to give massive credit to the sexual liberation movement, especially within the queer community, where a lot of this progress towards a more open relationship approach has originated.
beliefs about monogamy that arose from very Puritan religious influences. However, many people have pointed to the new age theory that monogamy is a socially rather than naturally biologically constructed idea. And with access to things like the internet and books and even influences, individuals are showing a very big interest nowadays. We also have to give massive credit to the sexual liberation movement, especially within the queer community, where a lot of this progress towards a more open relationship approach has originated.|||源自清教徒宗教影响的一夫一妻制观念。然而，许多人指出了一种新时代理论，即一夫一妻制是一种社会构建的概念，而不是自然生物学构建的概念。随着接触到互联网、书籍甚至意见领袖等事物，个人如今表现出了极大的兴趣。我们还得大大归功于性解放运动，特别是在酷儿社群内部，朝着更开放的关系方法迈进的很多进展都源于此。
So terms like open relationship, polyamory, non-monogamy, swinging, they get thrown around a lot and confused quite a bit. They're used interchangeably. But they are different. An open relationship is somewhat of an umbrella. term that we use to refer to all relationship models in which two members of the union are not monogamous and therefore they're not only having sex and dating each other. I think a lot of us think it's just about sex and in some ways it is but it's also about being able to have different
So terms like open relationship, polyamory, non-monogamy, swinging, they get thrown around a lot and confused quite a bit. They're used interchangeably. But they are different. An open relationship is somewhat of an umbrella. term that we use to refer to all relationship models in which two members of the union are not monogamy and therefore they're not only having sex and dating each other. I think a lot of us think it's just about sex and in some ways it is but it's also about being able to have different|||因此，像开放式关系、多边恋、非一夫一妻制、换偶（swinging）这样的术语经常被抛出并经常被混淆。它们被交替使用。但它们是不同的。开放式关系在某种程度上是一个总括性术语，我们用它来指代所有的关系模型，其中结合部的两个成员并非一夫一妻制，因此他们不仅与对方发生性关系和约会。我想我们很多人认为这只关乎性，在某些方面确实如此，但它也关乎能够拥有不同的
romantic experiences with someone other than your partner and it essentially not being what we would call cheating because you've both had a discussion in which it's been allowed and there's been boundaries set up and both people are excited about it. However, it doesn't mean that you're allowed to be committed to these other individuals. You stay emotionally committed to your primary partner. This is different to polyamory or polyamorous relationships in which there is a permission there to be committed to multiple partners. I think it's the degree of casualness to other relationships, that is the distinction between things like open relationships, polyamory, and even swinging, in which the other relationships are purely sexual.
romantic experiences with someone other than your partner and it essentially not being what we would call cheating because you've both had a discussion in which it's been allowed and there's been boundaries set up and both people are excited about it. However, it doesn't mean that you're allowed to be committed to these other individuals. You stay emotionally committed to your primary partner. This is different to polyamory or polyamorous relationships in which there is a permission there to be committed to multiple partners. I think it's the degree of casualness to other relationships, that is the distinction between things like open relationships, polyamory, and even swinging, in which the other relationships are purely sexual.|||与伴侣之外的人的浪漫体验，并且它本质上不是我们所说的出你们双方都进行了讨论，其中得到了允许并设定了界限，而且双方都对此感到兴奋。然而，这并不意味着你被允许对这些其他人做出承诺。你在情感上仍然忠于你的核心伴侣。这不同于多边恋或多配偶关系，在那种关系中，存在着对多个伴侣做出承诺的许可。我认为，对其他关系的随意程度，才是诸如开放式关系、多边恋甚至换偶之间的区别所在，在换偶中，其他关系纯粹是关于性的。
So I think if we think about non-monogamy on a hierarchy based on the degree of commitment within the relationships beyond our primary partnership, the most commitment would be in polyamorous relationships in which you can be equally in love and committed to another person, then there's open relationships whereby you can go on dates, you can have sex and romantic connections with others, but you cannot offer commitment. And then finally, swinging, which is purely sexual. But we are just going to talk about open relationships today. We're going to keep it limited because we could go on for hours if we talked about all of
So I think if we think about non-monogamy on a hierarchy based on the degree of commitment within the relationships beyond our primary partnership, the most commitment would be in polyamorous relationships in which you can be equally in love and committed to another person, then there's open relationships whereby you can go on dates, you can have sex and romantic connections with others, but you cannot offer commitment. And then finally, swinging, which is purely sexual. But we are just going to talk about open relationships today. We're going to keep it limited because we could go on for hours if we talked about all of|||因此，如果我们根据超越核心伴侣关系的关系中的承诺程度，将非一夫一妻制置于一个等级制度中，承诺最高的是多边恋关系，在其中你可以同样地爱另一个人并对其实施承诺，然后是开放式关系，你可以去约会，你可以与其他人发生性关系和建立浪漫连接，但你不能提供承诺。最后是换偶，这纯粹是关于性的。但我们今天只谈论开放式关系。我们将把范围限制在这上面，因为如果我们把所有的都谈一遍，我们可以讲上好几个小时。
them. And I also think that open relationships are the most relevant to our 20s because I think they're the most common. If we just want sex, we know. that in our 20s, that is something that a lot of other people will want. And it's easier to go looking for it. It's easier to find it because others our age will be in a similar mind frame. And we may not necessarily want commitment within that. Most of us are also not married yet, especially in our early 20s. So swinging within a couple is likely uncommon, but not impossible.
them. And I also think that open relationships are the most relevant to our 20s because I think they're the most common. If we just want sex, we know. that in our 20s, that is something that a lot of other people will want. And it's easier to go looking for it. It's easier to find it because others our age will be in a similar mind frame. And we may not necessarily want commitment within that. Most of us are also not married yet, especially in our early 20s. So swinging within a couple is likely uncommon, but not impossible.|||而且我也认为开放式关系与我们的20多岁最相关，因为我认为它们最常见。如果我们只是想要性，我们知道，在我们的20多岁，那是许多其他人也会想要的东西。而且寻找它更容易。更容易找到，因为我们这个年纪的其他人在心态上会很相似。而且我们不一定想在其中得到承诺。我们大多数人也还没结婚，特别是在20岁出头的时候。所以情侣之间的换偶可能不太常见，但并非不可能。
And we're also not necessarily looking for polyamory. I feel like most of us in our 20s, are still struggling to even maintain one romantic relationships, and we're still developing our emotional maturity. So managing the complexity of multiple partners is also going to be a lot less frequent during this decade. I think open relationships are our sweet spot for those who are seeking out non-monogamy in our 20s. We want the emotional stability of a partner, that's security, a commitment and a deep bond. but our 20s are also sold to us as a time of exploration and sexual freedom, so we may not want to miss out.
And we're also not necessarily looking for polyamory. I feel like most of us in our 20s, are still struggling to even maintain one romantic relationships, and we're still developing our emotional maturity. So managing the complexity of multiple partners is also going to be a lot less frequent during this decade. I think open relationships are our sweet spot for those who are seeking out non-monogamy in our 20s. We want the emotional stability of a partner, that's security, a commitment and a deep bond. but our 20s are also sold to us as a time of exploration and sexual freedom, so we may not want to miss out.|||而且我们也不一定在寻找多边恋。我觉得我们20多岁的大多数人还在努力维系一段恋爱关系，而且我们的情感成熟度仍在发展。因此，在这个十年中，管理多个伴侣的复杂性的情况也会少得多。我认为对于那些在20多岁时寻求非一夫一妻制的人来说，开放式关系是我们的最佳选择。我们想要伴侣带来的情感稳定，即安全感、承诺和深厚的羁绊。但20多岁也被兜售给我们，作为探索和性自由的时期，所以我们可能不想错过。
Our next question then is, why does some people want this kind of sexual and romantic freedom or choice that is promised to them in an open relationship? And what makes these people different from traditional monogamous, like myself in the world? You know, I don't think it's for everyone. and when we examine the psychology, we get a better idea as to why. The first thing I would point to is personality.
Our next question then is, why does some people want this kind of sexual and romantic freedom or choice that is promised to them in an open relationship? And what makes these people different from traditional monogamous, like myself in the world? You know, I don't think it's for everyone. and when we examine the psychology, we get a better idea as to why. The first thing I would point to is personality.|||那么我们的下一个问题是，为什么有些人想要这种在开放式关系中向他们承诺的性与浪漫的自由或选择？是什么让这些人与传统的一夫一妻制者（比如世上的我）有所不同？你知道的，我认为这并不适合所有人。当我们审视心理学时，我们就能更好地理解其中的原因。我要指出的第一件事是性格。
We know that personality impacts many of our perspectives and perceptions, as well as our choices and our habits. This includes our approach to dating and relationships, and as well as that, our opinions on monogamy. Research has shown that certain Big Five personality traits, can be linked to a greater acceptance and willingness to pursue non-monogamy. For those of us who don't know what the big five is, it's essentially an approach to understanding personality based on five specific personality traits that are the building blocks of our character
We know that personality impacts many of our perspectives and perceptions, as well as our choices and our habits. This includes our approach to dating and relationships, and as well as that, our opinions on monogamy. Research has shown that certain Big Five personality traits, can be linked to a greater acceptance and willingness to pursue non-monogamy. For those of us who don't know what the big five is, it's essentially an approach to understanding personality based on five specific personality traits that are the building blocks of our character|||我们知道，性格会影响我们的许多观点和看法，以及我们的选择和习惯。这包括我们对待约会和关系的方式，以及我们对一夫一妻制的看法。研究表明，某些“大五人格”特质与对非一夫一妻制更高的接纳度和追求意愿有关。对于我们中不知道什么是大五人格的人来说，它本质上是一种基于五种特定人格特质来理解人格的方法，这些特质是我们性格的基石
and who we are. These are openness to new experiences, conscientiousness, extroversion, neuroticism, and agreeableness. each of these five primary personality traits exists on a spectrum between two extremes. For example, the trait of extroversion, its extreme is introversion. And people exist between the two pillars on either side. And by examining where people sit upon this spectrum for each of these traits, psychologists have reasoned that we can map how personality influences our decisions across a number of areas including our relationships.
and who we are. These are openness to new experiences, conscientiousness, extroversion, neuroticism, and agreeableness. each of these five primary personality traits exists on a spectrum between two extremes. For example, the trait of extroversion, its extreme is introversion. And people exist between the two pillars on either side. And by examining where people sit upon this spectrum for each of these traits, psychologists have reasoned that we can map how personality influences our decisions across a number of areas including our relationships.|||以及我们是谁。它们是：开放性、尽责性、外向性、神经质和宜人性。这五种主要的人格特质中的每一种都存在于两个极端之间的光谱上。例如，外向性这一特质，它的极端是内向。人们存在于两侧的两个支柱之间。通过检查人们在这些特质的光谱上处于什么位置，心理学家推断我们可以绘制出人格如何影响我们在多个领域的决策，包括我们的关系。
Two traits in particular seem to be particularly relevant in this conversation. Studies have shown that extroversion and openness to experiences, strongly predicted attitudes, and our willingness to engage in consensual non-monogamy. There is a fairly old study that was done on this, and it focused on consensual non-monogamy, and its correlation to the Big Five personality traits, amongst LGBTQIA plus individuals, and it found that participants who were in open relationships scored higher on openness to experiences, extroversion, and a lot lower on neuroticism subscales
Two traits in particular seem to be particularly relevant in this conversation. Studies have shown that extroversion and openness to experiences, strongly predicted attitudes, and our willingness to engage in consensual non-monogamy. There is a fairly old study that was done on this, and it focused on consensual non-monogamy, and its correlation to the Big Five personality traits, amongst LGBTQIA plus individuals, and it found that participants who were in open relationships scored higher on openness to experiences, extroversion, and a lot lower on neuroticism subscales|||其中有两项特质在这场对话中似乎尤为相关。研究表明，外向性和对体验的开放性，强烈预测了态度以及我们参与知情同意的非一夫一妻制的意愿。有一项关于此的相当古老的研究，它重点关注知情同意的非一夫一妻制，以及它与LGBTQIA+群体中“大五人格”特质的相关性，结果发现，处于开放式关系中的参与者在对体验的开放性、外向性得分更高，而在神经质子量表上的得分要低得多
than those in monogamous relationships. This naturally makes a lot of sense. If you're rating higher on openness to experiences, it's likely that this will also include a receptiveness to new sexual experiences and engaging and exploring some of those connections that are offered up by an open relationship. Agreeableness is another Big Five personality trait and it may also be linked to someone's likelihood of agreeing to an open relationship if their partners suggest one. This may not always be a positive thing though. We'll talk about this later but open relationships, they really work if one party is not fully committed, excited or dedicated to the idea. And it can create a bit of a power imbalance and even resentment, which is just going to cause that relationship to crumble
than those in monogamous relationships. This naturally makes a lot of sense. If you're rating higher on openness to experiences, it's likely that this will also include a receptiveness to new sexual experiences and engaging and exploring some of those connections that are offered up by an open relationship. Agreeableness is another Big Five personality trait and it may also be linked to someone's likelihood of agreeing to an open relationship if their partners suggest one. This may not always be a positive thing though. We'll talk about this later but open relationships, they really work if one party is not fully committed, excited or dedicated to the idea. And it can create a bit of a power imbalance and even resentment, which is just going to cause that relationship to crumble|||比那些处于一夫一妻制关系中的人。这自然很有道理。如果你在体验开放性方面的得分更高，这可能也包括对新性经验的接受度，以及参与和探索开放式关系所提供的某些连接。宜人是另一个大五人格特质，如果伴侣提出建议，它也可能与某人同意开放式关系的可能性有关。不过这并不总是积极的事情。我们稍后会讨论这一点，但开放式关系，如果一方没有完全致力于、兴奋于或投入于这个想法，它们确实很难奏效。这会造成一些权力失衡甚至怨恨，这只会导致这段关系崩溃
under the pressure. But we're going to talk about that more in one second. I want to finish up on personality and how it links to open relationships. There are other personality traits, really crucial ones that are not related to the big five but are linked to someone's curiosity and willingness to pursue an open relationship. These include things like our flexibility, how adaptive we are to change. Of course, I think that makes a lot of sense. I feel like I don't need to explain why flexibility and open relationships are linked. And also things like honesty and non-conformance to tradition. So research has identified that people who are more naturally inclined to oppose authority or widely held cultural or societal beliefs are more receptive to a relationship that is also
under the pressure. But we're going to talk about that more in one second. I want to finish up on personality and how it links to open relationships. There are other personality traits, really crucial ones that are not related to the big five but are linked to someone's curiosity and willingness to pursue an open relationship. These include things like our flexibility, how adaptive we are to change. Of course, I think that makes a lot of sense. I feel like I don't need to explain why flexibility and open relationships are linked. And also things like honesty and non-conformance to tradition. So research has identified that people who are more naturally inclined to oppose authority or widely held cultural or societal beliefs are more receptive to a relationship that is also|||在压力下。但我们马上会对此进行更多讨论。我想讲完性格以及它如何与开放式关系联系起来。还有其他一些性格特质，非常关键的特质，它们与大五人格无关，但与某人对开放式关系的好奇心和追求意愿有关。其中包括我们的灵活性、我们对变化的适应能力等事情。当然，我认为这很有意义。我觉得我不需要解释为什么灵活性和开放式关系是相关的。还有诚实以及对传统的不顺从等事情。因此研究发现，那些更倾向于反抗权威或广泛持有的文化或社会信仰的人，对于
not conforming or untraditional. I find that so fascinating because I don't think it's typically what we expect when we examine the personality differences behind our willingness to pursue non-monogamy, but this characteristic and natural inclination away from the norm does make a lot of sense for people who are more attracted to the idea of an open relationship because it isn't the norm and it is, well, it does kind of go against a lot of our traditional beliefs. Now, a disclaimer, if you are personally extroverted or you do typically like to question authority and ingrained ways of thinking or your high on agreeableness, that doesn't necessarily mean that you're, you know,
not conforming or untraditional. I find that so fascinating because I don't think it's typically what we expect when we examine the personality differences behind our willingness to pursue non-monogamy, but this characteristic and natural inclination away from the norm does make a lot of sense for people who are more attracted to the idea of an open relationship because it isn't the norm and it is, well, it does kind of go against a lot of our traditional beliefs. Now, a disclaimer, if you are personally extroverted or you do typically like to question authority and ingrained ways of thinking or your high on agreeableness, that doesn't necessarily mean that you're, you know,|||不墨守成规或非传统的恋情也更能接受。我觉得这太吸引人了，因为当我们审视我们追求非一夫一妻制意愿背后的性格差异时，我认为这通常不是我们的预期，但这种特征以及对常态的天然偏离对于那些更容易被开放式关系吸引的人来说确实很有道理，因为这不是常态，而且它，嗯，确实有点违背我们的许多传统信仰。现在，作一个免责声明，如果你个人很外向，或者你通常喜欢质疑权威和根深蒂固的思维方式，或者你的宜人度很高，这并不一定意味着你，你知道的，
You should approach your partner right this second and tell them you want to open your relationship. Each person has their own unique personality profile and there are other factors that are going to play a role. Also, it's just personal preference, right? Like if you are not excited by the idea, your personality and what you know about it doesn't really matter, right? It's just one explanation that has been offered up. Another one, though, has to do with sociosexuality. So we talked about this in our episode on hookup culture, but sociosexuality is defined as an individual's interest in uncommitted sexual activity. A study conducted out of the US in 2017, it found that romantically involved individuals are more likely to engage in infidelity or want to pursue.
You should approach your partner right this second and tell them you want to open your relationship. Each person has their own unique personality profile and there are other factors that are going to play a role. Also, it's just personal preference, right? Like if you are not excited by the idea, your personality and what you know about it doesn't really matter, right? It's just one explanation that has been offered up. Another one, though, has to do with sociosexuality. So we talked about this in our episode on hookup culture, but sociosexuality is defined as an individual's interest in uncommitted sexual activity. A study conducted out of the US in 2017, it found that romantically involved individuals are more likely to engage in infidelity or want to pursue.|||你应该现在就去找你的伴侣，告诉他们你想开放你们的关系。每个人都有自己独特的人格画像，还有其他因素会发挥作用。而且，这也只是个人偏好，对吧？就像如果你对这个想法不感兴趣，你的性格以及你对它的了解其实并不重要，对吧？这只是提出的其中一种解释。不过，另一个解释与社会性有关。我们在关于约会文化的节目中谈到过这个，但社会性被定义为个人对无承诺性活动的兴趣。美国在2017年进行的一项研究发现，处于恋爱关系中的个人更有可能出轨或想要追求。
you casual sex or connections when they are more unrestricted in their sociosexuality. In the same study, they showed that men are more sociosexually unrestricted, meaning more interested in uncommitted sex compared to their female counterparts. So gender also may play a role in a person's curiosity around non-monogamy and how that fits in with their broader perspectives on romance and sex and intimacy. This doesn't surprise me on a personal level because in every instance that I have seen of an open relationship just personally, it has always been the man who has first put the idea on the table. It's not to say that women aren't equally interested in casual sex or
you casual sex or connections when they are more unrestricted in their sociosexuality. In the same study, they showed that men are more sociosexually unrestricted, meaning more interested in uncommitted sex compared to their female counterparts. So gender also may play a role in a person's curiosity around non-monogamy and how that fits in with their broader perspectives on romance and sex and intimacy. This doesn't surprise me on a personal level because in every instance that I have seen of an open relationship just personally, it has always been the man who has first put the idea on the table. It's not to say that women aren't equally interested in casual sex or|||当你对社会的开放度更加不受束缚时，你会有随意的性行为或连接。在同一项研究中，他们表明，与女性相比，男性在社会性方面更加不受束缚，这意味着对无承诺的性行为更感兴趣。因此，性别也可能在一个人对非一夫一妻的好奇心以及这如何融入他们对浪漫、性和亲密的更广泛视角中发挥作用。这在个人层面上并没有让我感到惊讶，因为就我个人所见过的每一个开放式关系的例子中，总是男性首先提出这个想法的。这并不是说女性对随意的性行为同样不感兴趣，或者
opening their relationship or exploring uncommitted romantic connections, but men are often more unrestricted in this domain, especially due to their sociosexuality. And it's an ingrained trait. It's something that's very hard to change. So it does explain where some people have more of a desire for this arrangement compared to others. There is something else that I think needs further examining when we discuss open relationships, and that is the role. of sexuality and the influence of the LGBTIQIA plus community on our increasing openness and receptiveness towards non-monogamy as a society. We are taught from a young age that a normal relationship involves a man and a woman and they are aiming for marriage. They're aiming for
opening their relationship or exploring uncommitted romantic connections, but men are often more unrestricted in this domain, especially due to their sociosexuality. And it's an ingrained trait. It's something that's very hard to change. So it does explain where some people have more of a desire for this arrangement compared to others. There is something else that I think needs further examining when we discuss open relationships, and that is the role. of sexuality and the influence of the LGBTIQIA plus community on our increasing openness and receptiveness towards non-monogamy as a society. We are taught from a young age that a normal relationship involves a man and a woman and they are aiming for marriage. They're aiming for|||开放他们的关系或探索无承诺的浪漫连接，但男性在这个领域通常更不受束缚，特别是由于他们的社会性。这是一种根深蒂固的特质。这是非常难改变的事情。所以这确实解释了为什么有些人对这种安排的渴望比其他人更强烈。当我们讨论开放式关系时，我认为还有一件事需要进一步审视，那就是性取向的作用，以及LGBTIQIA+社群对我们作为一个社会对非一夫一妻制的开放度和接受度不断提高的影响。我们从小就被教导，正常的关系涉及一个男人和一个女人，他们的目标是结婚。他们的目标是
marriage and children. And this has been questioned both in relation to the core idea of monogamy and having one partner for the rest of our lives, and also by our greater acceptance of non-heteronormative relationships. Relationships between men and women are not the only ones that exist, and they've never been the only ones to exist. And that questioning of heteronormative ideas around relationships has also led us to question that core idea of monogamy. And studies have shown that a higher percentage of individuals who identify as,
marriage and children. And this has been questioned both in relation to the core idea of monogamy and having one partner for the rest of our lives, and also by our greater acceptance of non-heteronormative relationships. Relationships between men and women are not the only ones that exist, and they've never been the only ones to exist. And that questioning of heteronormative ideas around relationships has also led us to question that core idea of monogamy. And studies have shown that a higher percentage of individuals who identify as,|||婚姻和孩子. 这既受到了一夫一妻制的核心理念以及余生只有一个伴侣的质疑，也受到了我们对非异性恋规范关系更大程度接受的质疑。男女之间的关系并不是唯一存在的关系，而且它们从来都不是唯一存在的关系。对围绕关系的异性恋规范理念的质疑也导致我们质疑一夫一妻制的核心理念。研究表明，更高百分比的个体被识别为，
lesbian, queer, bisexual, or as a member of this community, are in open non-monogamous relationships compared to hetero-sistgender couples. A new report that came out in Australia and also the US suggests that about a third of gay men are in open relationships. In a poll of, I think it was almost 600 gay men conducted in San Francisco, they found that 30% were not strictly monogamous with their partners. obviously we should take this with a grain of salt a lot of queer people also hold negative opinions of open relationships and are not interested in casual sex and no one is the same however rates do seem to be
lesbian, queer, bisexual, or as a member of this community, are in open non-monogamous relationships compared to hetero-sistgender couples. A new report that came out in Australia and also the US suggests that about a third of gay men are in open relationships. In a poll of, I think it was almost 600 gay men conducted in San Francisco, they found that 30% were not strictly non-monogamous with their partners. obviously we should take this with a grain of salt a lot of queer people also hold negative opinions of open relationships and are not interested in casual sex and no one is the same however rates do seem to be|||与异性顺性别伴侣相比，女同性恋、酷儿、双性恋或作为该社群成员的人处于开放的非一夫一妻制关系中。澳大利亚和美国发布的一项新报告表明，大约三分之一的男同性恋者处于开放式关系中。在旧金山进行的一项对近600名男同性恋者的民意调查中，他们发现30%的人对他们的伴侣并非严格的一夫一妻制。显然我们应该对这些数据持保留态度，许多酷儿对开放式关系也抱有负面看法，对随意的性行为不感兴趣，而且没有哪两个人是完全一样的，然而，这些比率似乎确实
higher compared to heterosexual couples and according to this incredible book the ethical slut which I would really recommend if you are curious about ethical non-monogamy the authors suggest that the reason we may see greater rates of this relationship model among amongst queer couples is because they are more comfortable and interested in exploring their sexuality because this is what they've been doing from a young age. You know, they grew up, they were raised in a society that had often confined their sexual expression. So according to this amazing advocate, Matt Hudson, most gay people will have grown up
higher compared to heterosexual couples and according to this incredible book the ethical slut which I would really recommend if you are curious about ethical non-monogamy the authors suggest that the reason we may see greater rates of this relationship model among amongst queer couples is because they are more comfortable and interested in exploring their sexuality because this is what they've been doing from a young age. You know, they grew up, they were raised in a society that had often confined their sexual expression. So according to this amazing advocate, Matt Hudson, most gay people will have grown up|||与异性恋情侣相比要高。根据这本令人惊叹的书《道德浪女》（The Ethical Slut），如果你对道德非一夫一妻制感到好奇，我强烈推荐这本书，作者认为我们可能会在酷儿情侣中看到更高比率的这种关系模型的原因是，他们对探索自己的性取向感到更加舒适和感兴趣，因为这是他们从小就在做的事情。你知道的，他们长大成人，在经常限制他们性表达的社会中长大。因此，根据这位出色的倡导者马特·哈德森（Matt Hudson）的说法，大多数同性恋者都是在
encountering attitudes that told them they were not normal, they were not accepted, and so as they've gotten older, they seek more exploration. They actually want to push back against those ideas and it means that they seek sexual satisfaction and relationship arrangements that are outside of the norm. That is just one kind of perspective that I thought was really important to share. Like I said before, a lot of our progress towards being more accepting of non-monogamy and different models of relationships did arise from the queer community and what they've done and their thoughts on the matter. So it's super, super interesting to see how sexuality, but also culture and society, kind of interact and intersect when we talk about
encountering attitudes that told them they were not normal, they were not accepted, and so as they've gotten older, they seek more exploration. They actually want to push back against those ideas and it means that they seek sexual satisfaction and relationship arrangements that are outside of the norm. That is just one kind of perspective that I thought was really important to share. Like I said before, a lot of our progress towards being more accepting of non-monogamy and different models of relationships did arise from the queer community and what they've done and their thoughts on the matter. So it's super, super interesting to see how sexuality, but also culture and society, kind of interact and intersect when we talk about|||遇到这样态度的环境中长大的，这些态度告诉他们自己是不正常的，是不被接受的，所以随着他们年龄的增长，他们寻求更多的探索。他们实际上想要反击这些想法，这意味着他们寻求超出规范的性满足和关系安排。这只是我认为非常重要分享的一种视角。就像我之前说的，我们在更加接受非一夫一妻制和不同关系模型方面取得的大部分进展，确实源于酷儿社群以及他们所做的事情和他们对这件事的看法. 因此，看到性取向，以及文化和社会，在我们谈论
non-monogamy. There's also been some preliminary research into the impact of asexuality, which is an individual who lacks sexual attraction to others, but still desires a relationship on a couple's willingness to enter an open relationship. It's known as a sexual polyamory. Okay, I'm quite naive when it comes to this, so I did try and do a bit of a deep dive to get it right, but if this does apply to you, definitely consult some outside sources. However, one study from the Journal of Sexual Positivity suggested that some asexual people have observed that polyamory open relationships, they seem to be more popular as a relationship style amongst asexual people than they are in the mainstream, perhaps because of a recognition that, sex is something that most people need or want and if their partner does not have the same desires and needs, if they don't really feel sexual attraction to others, maybe it's an effective compromise to seek an open relationship so that the other person can have their sexual needs
non-monogamy. There's also been some preliminary research into the impact of asexuality, which is an individual who lacks sexual attraction to others, but still desires a relationship on a couple's willingness to enter an open relationship. It's known as a sexual polyamory. Okay, I'm quite naive when it comes to this, so I did try and do a bit of a deep dive to get it right, but if this does apply to you, definitely consult some outside sources. However, one study from the Journal of Sexual Positivity suggested that some asexual people have observed that polyamory open relationships, they seem to be more popular as a relationship style amongst asexual people than they are in the mainstream, perhaps because of a recognition that, sex is something that most people need or want and if their partner does not have the same desires and needs, if they don't really feel sexual attraction to others, maybe it's an effective compromise to seek an open relationship so that the other person can have their sexual needs|||非一夫一妻制时如何相互作用和交叉，是非常非常有趣的事情。还有一些关于无性恋影响的初步研究，无性恋是指缺乏对他人性吸引力但仍然渴望关系的个人，这会如何影响情侣进入开放式关系的意愿。这被称为性多边恋。好吧，我对这方面相当天真，所以我确实尝试做了一些深入研究以弄明白，但这如果确实适用于你，请务必咨询一些外部来源。然而，《性积极性杂志》（Journal of Sexual Positivity）的一项研究表明，一些无性恋者观察到，多边恋开放式关系在无性恋者中似乎比在主流人群中更受欢迎，作为一种关系风格，这可能是因为人们认识到，性是大多数人需要或想要的东西，如果他们的伴侣没有相同的欲望和需求，如果他们真的对其他人没有性吸引力，也许寻求开放式关系是一种有效的妥协，这样另一个人就能满足他们的性需求
fulfilled elsewhere. I think it all comes down to personal preference and what works best for each couple, some people who are in relationships in which they are asexual or with an asexual partner don't do this. They find other ways to make it work or to compromise, but it's fascinating to see the impact of things like our sexual preferences and then also personality and sociosexuality on our receptiveness and eagerness to pursue multiple sexual partners, romantic connections, sexual connections beyond the stability of our core partnership. If you are someone who has only ever had monogamous relationships, I think we have a few apprehensions when it comes to open relationships that I want to break down.
fulfilled elsewhere. I think it all comes down to personal preference and what works best for each couple, some people who are in relationships in which they are asexual or with an asexual partner don't do this. They find other ways to make it work or to compromise, but it's fascinating to see the impact of things like our sexual preferences and then also personality and sociosexuality on our receptiveness and eagerness to pursue multiple sexual partners, romantic connections, sexual connections beyond the stability of our core partnership. If you are someone who has only ever had monogamous relationships, I think we have a few apprehensions when it comes to open relationships that I want to break down.|||在其他地方得到满足。我认为这归根结底取决于个人偏好以及对每对情侣最管用的方式，有些身处无性恋关系中或与无性恋伴侣在一起的人并没有这样做。他们找到了其他让它发挥作用或妥协的方法，但看到诸如我们的性偏好、性格和社会性等事物对我们接受并渴望追求核心伴侣关系稳定性之外的多个性伴侣、浪漫连接、性连接的影响，是件非常着迷的事。如果你是一个只经历过一夫一妻制关系的人，我想我们在面对开放式关系时有一些顾虑，我想将其打破。
It can be very alien and hard to understand if you've never encountered this type of dating and sex and some of the insecurities that it may bring up. So here are some of the most common opinions. or questions we have from my own perspective, but also discussions that I've had with friends. Firstly, if you are not interested in non-monogamy or open relationships, that is totally fine. We can recognize the impact of tradition and ingrained misperceptions of sex on our beliefs and still believe the things that we do. However, most of our biggest concerns do stem from this cognitive dissonance between what we have been taught to believe a relationship is,
It can be very alien and hard to understand if you've never encountered this type of dating and sex and some of the insecurities that it may bring up. So here are some of the most common opinions. or questions we have from my own perspective, but also discussions that I've had with friends. Firstly, if you are not interested in non-monogamy or open relationships, that is totally fine. We can recognize the impact of tradition and ingrained misperceptions of sex on our beliefs and still believe the things that we do. However, most of our biggest concerns do stem from this cognitive dissonance between what we have been taught to believe a relationship is,|||如果你从未接触过这种约会和性爱以及它可能带来的一些不安全感，这可能会非常陌生且难以理解。因此，以下是从我自己的视角以及我与朋友们的讨论中得出的一些最常见的观点或问题。首先，如果你对非一夫一妻制或开放式关系不感兴趣，那完全没问题。我们可以认识到传统和根深蒂固的关于性的错误观念对我们信念的影响，并且仍然相信我们所相信的事情。然而，我们大多数最大的担忧确实源于这种认知失调，即我们被教导相信的关系是什么，
and the ways in which open relationships force us to question that belief. The first one being, what is the point of being married or in a relationship if you're going to make your relationship open? Why have a relationship at all? Wouldn't it just be better to break up if you do want to have sex with other people? This is one of my major questions, but someone explained it to me like this recently. Relationships are not just about sex. If they were, then having sex with other people would definitely pose a major ex-essential challenge within open relationships.
and the ways in which open relationships force us to question that belief. The first one being, what is the point of being married or in a relationship if you're going to make your relationship open? Why have a relationship at all? Wouldn't it just be better to break up if you do want to have sex with other people? This is one of my major questions, but someone explained it to me like this recently. Relationships are not just about sex. If they were, then having sex with other people would definitely pose a major ex-external challenge within open relationships.|||以及开放式关系迫使我们质疑这种信念的方式。第一个是，如果你要让你的关系开放，那么结婚或处于恋爱关系中还有什么意义？为什么还要建立关系？如果你真的想和别人发生性关系，直接分手不是更好吗？这是我的主要问题之一，但最近有人向我这样解释。关系不仅仅关乎性。如果是这样的话，那么与其他人发生性关系肯定会在开放式关系中构成一个重大的外部挑战。
But relationships are more than that. They are about trust, an incredible bond between two people. They're about communication, memories, and of course, love. All of those things can still exist and remain strong, even if you're sleeping with other people and you have good boundaries around that practice. if we think that having sex with other people will ruin the commitment within our relationship, we are essentially just reducing all relationships to sex and we're ignoring all the other things that make them work. It's not to say that sex is meaningless or that it can pose a problem or can damage a partnership, but that relationships are more than just the physical.
But relationships are more than that. They are about trust, an incredible bond between two people. They're about communication, memories, and of course, love. All of those things can still exist and remain strong, even if you're sleeping with other people and you have good boundaries around that practice. if we think that having sex with other people will ruin the commitment within our relationship, we are essentially just reducing all relationships to sex and we're ignoring all the other things that make them work. It's not to say that sex is meaningless or that it can pose a problem or can damage a partnership, but that relationships are more than just the physical.|||但关系远不止于此。它们关乎信任，是两个人之间不可思议的纽带。它们关乎沟通、记忆，当然还有爱。所有这些事情仍然可以存在并保持强大，即使你与其他人上床并且你在这种做法周围有良好的界限。如果我们认为与其他人发生性关系会毁掉我们关系中的承诺，我们本质上只是把所有的关系都贬低为性，并且我们忽视了所有使它们起作用的其他事情。这并不是说性毫无意义，或者它不会构成问题或损害伴侣关系，而是说关系不仅仅是身体上的。
Another big misconception is that people who have open relationships, must just like sex more than others or their sex addicts, hence why they feel the need to be pursuing that with multiple people. They want to have their cake and they want to eat it too. That is also not necessarily true. Sometimes what they're seeking is new sexual experiences and connections, not necessarily just more sex. And in our 20s, that is something that a lot of us are looking for.
Another big misconception is that people who have open relationships, must just like sex more than others or their sex addicts, hence why they feel the need to be pursuing that with multiple people. They want to have their cake and they want to eat it too. That is also not necessarily true. Sometimes what they're seeking is new sexual experiences and connections, not necessarily just more sex. And in our 20s, that is something that a lot of us are looking for.|||另一个巨大的误解是，拥有开放式关系的人一定比其他人更喜欢性，或者他们是性瘾者，因此他们觉得有必要与多个人追求这一点。他们既想吃蛋糕又想留着它。这也是不一定正确的。有时他们寻求的是新的性经验和连接，而不一定只是更多的性。在我们的20多岁时，这是我们许多人正在寻找的东西。
This is one I struggle with because I think we have been led to believe that our partners should provide all that we need when it comes to our pleasure and how sexually fulfilled we are. Sometimes that is not possible if they're traveling or you live different lives in different cities or one partner is asexual and opening your relationship works best for you or maybe you do just like to have lots of sex but you love your partner. Two things can exist at once and it's important to appreciate. that people and couples do have different needs and joint attitudes towards the intersection between sex and commitment. You know, there have been many cultures and societies in which
This is one I struggle with because I think we have been led to believe that our partners should provide all that we need when it comes to our pleasure and how sexually fulfilled we are. Sometimes that is not possible if they're traveling or you live different lives in different cities or one partner is asexual and opening your relationship works best for you or maybe you do just like to have lots of sex but you love your partner. Two things can exist at once and it's important to appreciate. that people and couples do have different needs and joint attitudes towards the intersection between sex and commitment. You know, there have been many cultures and societies in which|||这是我一直在挣扎的一个问题，因为我认为我们一直被引导去相信，当涉及到我们的快乐和我们在性上有多满足时，我们的伴侣应该提供我们需要的一切。有时这是不可能的，如果他们正在旅行，或者你们在不同的城市过着不同的生活，或者其中一个伴侣是无性恋，而开放你的关系对你来说最管用，或者也许你真的很喜欢有很多性爱但你也爱你的伴侣。两件事可以同时存在，理解这一点很重要，那就是人和情侣确实对性与承诺的交集有不同的需求和共同的态度。你知道的，有很多文化和社群，其中
open relationships or polyamory have worked really well for generations and generations, and they weren't questioned and they weren't weird because traditional ideas of monogamy had never existed in those places. They found that this model was, was perhaps easier for raising children, for dealing with infertility, for growing their community, and building trust between all members of the group. It's not just a new idea, like I said at the start. It is a really valid model and system and perspective that has actually been proven to work for many, many societies and many, many cultures in the past.
open relationships or polyamory have worked really well for generations and generations, and they weren't questioned and they weren't weird because traditional ideas of monogamy had never existed in those places. They found that this model was, was perhaps easier for raising children, for dealing with infertility, for growing their community, and building trust between all members of the group. It's not just a new idea, like I said at the start. It is a really valid model and system and perspective that has actually been proven to work for many, many societies and many, many cultures in the past.|||开放式关系或多边恋代代相传都运行得非常好，它们没有受到质疑，也不奇怪，因为传统的一夫一妻制观念在这些地方从未存在过。他们发现这种模式可能更容易抚养孩子、处理不孕不育问题、发展社区以及在群体所有成员之间建立信任。正如我一开始所说，这不仅仅是一个新想法。它是一个非常有效的模型、系统和视角，实际上已被证明在过去对许多许多社会和许多许多文化都管用。
I think another big myth is that people in open relationships, would be cheating if their partners had not agreed to this arrangement. There's no specific studies on this, but many members of this community call this way of thinking quite reductive and judgmental because it doesn't take into consideration many of the boundaries and agreements and discussions that have been put in place to keep the relationship and the arrangement safe and respectful for all parties. Whilst we might label what is occurring in a non-monogamous relationship, as cheating. I think a core part of cheating or infidelity is dishonesty and secrecy. In open
I think another big myth is that people in open relationships, would be cheating if their partners had not agreed to this arrangement. There's no specific studies on this, but many members of this community call this way of thinking quite reductive and judgmental because it doesn't take into consideration many of the boundaries and agreements and discussions that have been put in place to keep the relationship and the arrangement safe and respectful for all parties. Whilst we might label what is occurring in a non-monogamous relationship, as cheating. I think a core part of cheating or infidelity is dishonesty and secrecy. In open|||我认为另一个巨大的神话是，如果伴侣没有同意这种安排，开放式关系中的人就是在出轨。对此没有具体的的研究，但该社群的许多成员认为这种思维方式相当简化且带有评判性，因为它没有考虑到许多已经建立的界限、协议和讨论，以确保关系和安排对各方都是安全和尊重的。虽然我们可能会将在非一夫一妻制关系中发生的事情贴上出轨的标签。我认为出轨或不忠的核心部分是不诚实和保密。在开放式
relationships, there isn't as much of that, especially around sex, because every member is clear on the structure. They are excited about being there, they're willing to be there, they're free to leave, and there is a lot more honesty and openness around the fact that both members are probably having sex with other people, and that is okay. Finally, a lot of us may think that open relationships are doomed to fail. And they're only really introduced into a partnership when one or both members are actually already ready to break up, but they can't quite bring themselves to recognize that. In some cases, that may be true, but on a case-by-case basis, because open relationships do work, and they work really well for some people and for some couples. So what's the secret? When do they work
relationships, there isn't as much of that, especially around sex, because every member is clear on the structure. They are excited about being there, they're willing to be there, they're free to leave, and there is a lot more honesty and openness around the fact that both members are probably having sex with other people, and that is okay. Finally, a lot of us may think that open relationships are doomed to fail. And they're only really introduced into a partnership when one or both members are actually already ready to break up, but they can't quite bring themselves to recognize that. In some cases, that may be true, but on a case-by-case basis, because open relationships do work, and they work really well for some people and for some couples. So what's the secret? When do they work|||关系中，这种情况没有那么多，特别是在性方面，因为每个成员都对结构很清楚。他们对身处其中感到兴奋，他们愿意身处其中，他们可以自由离开，并且围绕双方可能都在与其他人发生性关系这一事实，有更多的诚实和开放，这没关系。最后，我们很多人可能会认为开放式关系注定会失败。而且只有当其中一名成员或双方实际上已经准备好分手，但他们又无法承认这一点时，它们才真正被引入伴侣关系中。在某些情况下，这可能是真的，但要具体情况具体分析，因为开放式关系确实管用，而且对某些人和某些情侣来说，它们真的非常管用。那么秘诀是什么？它们什么时候管用
well, when do they not? What are the conditions for success? And finally, what does it mean to perhaps be the outsider or the other person in one of these partnerships? All of that and more in just a second. If you are thinking about opening your relationship or just curious about how they can be successful, there are a few things that we need to know about ourselves and our partner before jumping straight in. open relationships, they do work, but they are also incredibly fluid. They can stop and start and each are very unique. However, when I was looking into this idea, there was a lot of anecdotal and evidence-based insights that suggested some conditions have to be met if this arrangement and this dynamic
well, when do they not? What are the conditions for success? And finally, what does it mean to perhaps be the outsider or the other person in one of these partnerships? All of that and more in just a second. If you are thinking about opening your relationship or just curious about how they can be successful, there are a few things that we need to know about ourselves and our partner before jumping straight in. open relationships, they do work, but they are also incredibly fluid. They can stop and start and each are very unique. However, when I was looking into this idea, there was a lot of anecdotal and evidence-based insights that suggested some conditions have to be met if this arrangement and this dynamic|||什么时候不管用？成功的条件是什么？最后，在这些伴侣关系中成为局外人或“第三者”可能意味着什么？所有这些以及更多内容将在稍后揭晓。如果你正在考虑开放你们的关系，或者只是好奇它们如何才能成功，在直接跳进去之前，我们需要了解自己和伴侣的一些事情。开放式关系确实管用，但它们也极其不稳定和多变。它们可以随时停止和开始，并且每个都非常独特。然而，当我研究这个想法时，有许多轶事和基于证据的见解表明，如果这种安排和这种动态要保持健康，就必须满足一些条件
is going to be healthy. Firstly, both parties need to be on the same page. if one person is not into it, there's no point in even trying because you need to have strong foundations and you need to both be in agreement. That's what makes it consensual. I think strong foundations are essential in any relationship, but especially a situation where things can get murky quite quickly and you are letting other people into your relationship, especially when it's sexual as well.
is going to be healthy. Firstly, both parties need to be on the same page. if one person is not into it, there's no point in even trying because you need to have strong foundations and you need to both be in agreement. That's what makes it consensual. I think strong foundations are essential in any relationship, but especially a situation where things can get murky quite quickly and you are letting other people into your relationship, especially when it's sexual as well.|||首先双方需要在同一频道上。如果一个人不感兴趣，甚至都没有尝试的必要，因为你需要有牢固的基础，并且你们需要达成一致。这才是让它成为知情同意的关键。我认为牢固的基础在任何关系中都是必不可少的，尤其是在这种事情可能会很快变得扑朔迷离且你正在让其他人进入你的关系的情况中，特别是当它也涉及性的时候。
You know, if you're dragging someone into this situation, if they're hesitant, If you need to pressure them, not only is that incredibly unfair, but it's probably going to do a lot of damage, not just to your relationship, but also to that person's self-esteem and their long-term attachment style. Just don't do that. I think with most things, a no does not mean convince me, and some people are just monogamous individuals. But if it's a yes or there is some initial curiosity, you need to have a discussion around boundaries because these are, A, what is going to keep you safe,
你知道，如果你把某人拉进这种境况，如果他们有所犹豫，如果你需要向他们施压，这不仅极其不公平，而且很可能会造成巨大的破坏，不仅破坏你们的关系，还会破坏那个人的自尊心以及他们长期的依恋模式。千万别这么做。我认为对于大多数事情来说，“不”并不意味着“说服我”，而且有些人天生就是一夫一妻制的人。但如果这是一个“是”或者存在一些最初的好奇心，你需要围绕边界展开讨论，因为这些是，A，能保证你安全的东西，
what is going to prevent resentment and hurt, and also it's going to allow your relationship to continue steadily. I have friends of mine who are in open relationships, and they have some very strict boundaries that they have put in place together. It was a collaborative effort. Some of the rules they have include not seeing someone else more than twice a month, not dating friends or friending anybody they sleep with on social media, never inviting someone back to the place they share, which for me seems like a no-brainer, and things like always using
能防止怨恨和伤害的东西，并且它还能让你们的关系稳步继续。我的朋友中有处于开放式关系中的，他们共同制定了一些非常严格的边界。这是大家共同努力的结果。他们的一些规则包括：一个月与其他人见面不超过两次，不约会朋友，也不在社交媒体上加任何他们发生过性关系的人的好友，绝不邀请任何人回到他们共同居住的地方对我来说这简直是不言而喻的常识，以及诸如总是使用
protection. And also these varying levels of not so much secrecy, but, or not honesty either, but the varying levels that they're willing to share about the other people they're sleeping with or dating. I think the more specific, the better. But, one of those boundaries is particularly important and that's around being safe and using protection. You know, if it's not physically safe, it's not mentally safe and STDs are not something to muck around with. You just have to understand that you're taking a risk by sleeping with other people as you do whenever you have sex and make sure that both partners are safe in that arrangement. I think you also need to be in a good place mentally and have a handle on what trick. you in your monogamous relationship before making it non-monogamous. Those things, it's not going
保护措施之类的事情。还有这些不同程度的，与其说是保密，不如说，也不是不诚实，而是他们愿意分享关于他们正在与之发生性关系或约会其他人的不同程度。我认为越具体越好。但是，其中一个界限尤为重要，那就是关于保持安全和使用保护措施。你知道，如果身体上不安全，精神上就不安全，性病可不是闹着玩的。你必须明白，和与其他人发生性就像你每次做爱时一样是在承担风险，并确保双方在这种安排下都是安全的。我认为你还需要处于一个良好的精神状态，并且在让关系变成非一夫一妻制之前，先掌控住你在单偶关系中会被什么所
to change, right? If it's something that upsets you when it's just you to, especially around jealousy or resentment or rejection, it's still going to trigger you when your relationship is open. Things like jealousy, attachment styles, childhood wounds, abandonment issues. They are all included in this realization and this discussion. Most people's biggest operational. positions to open relationships is that they create jealousy that doesn't need to be there. We may be constantly worried that our partner will find someone else. They're going to fall madly in love with them and leave us. Or there is this constant suspicion or concern that your partner is having better sex with
触发的事情。那些东西是不会改变的，对吧？如果当只有你们两个人的时候，某些事情会让你心烦意乱，尤其是围绕嫉妒、怨恨或拒绝，那么当你们的关系开放时，它依然会触发你。诸如嫉妒、依恋模式、童年创伤、被抛弃感等问题。这些都被包含在这个认知和讨论中。大多数人对开放式关系最大的反对意见是，它们会产生本不该存在的嫉妒。我们可能会经常担心伴侣会找到别人。他们会疯狂地爱上对方并离开我们。或者会有一种挥之不去的怀疑或担忧，觉得你的伴侣和其他人
other people or likes the people they're dating more than you. And I think that's a really fair fear. But many of these fears are rooted in unconscious jealousy. and they're unlikely to be true. Everything will be different with another person, not better or worse. And if you are in a place in your relationship whereby you have a strong partnership that is not easily replaceable, I think that it is a very liberating idea sometimes to remove sexual and romantic ownership over each other and remember that you are choosing to be with each other, not out of habit or for lack of other options,
发生性关系时会更好，或者比起你，他们更喜欢自己正在约会的人。我认为这是一个非常合理的恐惧。但许多这种恐惧都根植于无意识的嫉妒之中，而且它们不太可能是真的。与其他人的经历都会有所不同，无所谓更好或更糟。如果你处于这样一种关系状态：你们拥有一个不容易被取代的牢固伙伴关系，我认为打破彼此对性和浪漫的占有欲，并记住你们选择和对方在一起不是出于习惯或缺乏其他选择，有时是一个非常解放的想法，
but because you do love the other person and you want them in your life, but you also want them to be free and allow to explore other things or other interests or other sexual fantasies or sexual proclivities that they may have. I will say, though, we do all differ in our levels of innate intrinsic jealousy. If you are a naturally very jealous person, if you find that things around dating and sex and relationships do naturally trigger you to be resentful or envious or jealous, that is going to greatly influence how your open relationship is going to work. And it will impact your well-being. You'll impact your long-term partnership.
而是因为你确实爱对方，希望他们在你的人生中，但也希望他们能自由并被允许探索其他事物、其他兴趣或他们可能拥有的其他性幻想或性癖好。不过我要说的是，我们所有人天生的内在嫉妒水平确实各不相同。如果你天生是一个非常嫉妒的人，如果你发现围绕约会、性行为和关系的种种事情自然而然地会触发你的怨恨、嫉妒或吃醋情绪，那将极大地影响你们的开放式关系将如何运作。并且它会影响你的幸福感。也会影响你们长期的伴侣关系。
You need to examine where that comes from, why you feel more intrinsically jealous. It's not your fault. You know what I mean? Like, it's really from a combination of factors. It's from things in your childhood. It's from early romantic relationships. But jealousy is always going to be a part of this situation, I think, and if you don't examine that and you don't have an open dialogue with your partner around what exactly makes you jealous and how that can be avoided, then you're kind of doomed to fail. Other personal factors beyond jealousy are also going to determine the success of an open relationship. One of those being attachment style, which I think is so crucial. It's a crucial conversation to be had even if you're not in a non-monogamous relationship.
你需要审视这种情绪的来源，为什么你内心深处更容易感到嫉妒。这不是你的错。你知道我的意思吗？这其实是多种因素结合的结果。它源于你的童年经历。它源于早期的恋爱关系。但我认为嫉妒将永远是这种情况的一部分，如果你不审视这一点，并且不与你的伴侣就究竟是什么让你嫉妒以及如何避免这种情况进行公开对话，那么你们的失败基本上就注定了。除了嫉妒之外的其他个人因素也将决定开放式关系的成功与否。其中之一就是依恋风格，我认为这至关重要。即使你没有处于非一夫一妻制的关系中，这也是一次至关重要的对话。
But if you are anxiously attached, this arrangement might not work for you because the idea of your partner going out, sleeping with other people, sharing stories with them, going on dates, laughing at their jokes. It may be incredibly triggering of your childhood attachment wounds, especially wounds surrounding abandonment and rejection. If you haven't worked through that, you're going to find it incredibly difficult to understand. that your partner will be doing those things and that you have allowed them to do that, but also that you're allowed to do that as well. Equally, if you have an avoidant attachment style, this relationship model may actually work really well for you on paper, but it may also cause you difficulties because you are already naturally opposed or hesitant around emotional intimacy and commitment.
但如果你是焦虑型依恋，这种安排可能不适合你，因为你的伴侣出去、与其他人发生性关系、与他们分享故事、约会、对他们的笑话大笑的想法。这可能会极大地触动你童年的依恋创伤，尤其是围绕被抛弃和拒绝的创伤。如果你没有解决好这些问题，你会发现自己很难理解你的伴侣会做这些事，而且你允许他们这样做，但同时也允许你自己这样做。同样，如果你是回避型依恋风格，这种关系模式在纸面上可能真的很适合你，但它也可能给你带来困难，因为你本身就天生排斥或犹豫于情感上的亲密与承诺。
So if you then open your relationship, it might mean that you're actually putting a buffer to prevent you and your partner from ever actually reaching that level of emotional closeness because you are scared. Be aware of your attachment style and what leaves you feeling insecure or in a bad headspace, particularly around sex and intimacy in dating, before deciding to jump right in. There are a few other factors like communication, trust and of course, honesty, which are fundamental, but I want to zoom out for a second and talk about what it's like to be the third party or the other person in this situation. All right, story time, vulnerable moment. I know I said I wasn't a fan of open relationships in my personal life, but I've actually been involved, I've dated, I've been intimate with a couple of people who have been in open relationships. For a while before I realized that dating these people was a sign of my own
所以如果你接着开放你们的关系，这可能意味着你实际上是在设置一个缓冲，以防止你和你的伴侣真正达到那种情感亲密的高度，因为你感到害怕。在决定一头扎进去之前，要了解自己的依恋风格，以及是什么让你感到不安全或心情糟糕，尤其是在约会中的性和亲密关系方面。还有沟通、信任以及当然还有诚意等其他几个因素，它们是至关重要的，但我想要把镜头拉远一点，谈谈在这种情况下作为第三方或另一个人是什么感觉。好了，故事时间，展现脆弱的时刻。我知道我说过在个人生活中我不喜欢开放式关系，但我实际上确实参与过，我和几个处于开放式关系中的人约会过，有过亲密关系。有一段时间，直到我意识到与这些人约会是我自己的
emotional unavailability, these men were like kryptonite to me. The ultimate no strings attached arrangement because I knew that they would never want anything more. I think I even had like a prompt about ethical non-monogamy on my hinge profile. And the truth is I would not do it again because I'm not too interested in casual relationships anymore, but I did learn a lot about how to behave as the third person or the outsider in these circumstances and also how these people's relationships and their openness and communication could really inform the standard I had for my own long-term partners. Even though I'm looking for monogamy, there was a lot to take away from what I observed.
情感不可得的一个征兆，这些男人对我来说就像氪石一样。终极的无拘无束的安排，因为我知道他们绝不会想要更多。我想我甚至在我的 Hinge 个人资料上有一个关于道德非一夫一妻制的提示。事实是，我不会再这样做了，因为我对随意的关系不再那么感兴趣，但我确实学到了很多关于在这种情况下如何作为第三者或局外人表现良好，以及这些人关系中的开放性和沟通如何能真正为我对我自己的长期伴侣所设的标准提供参考。尽管我在寻找一夫一妻制，但我从我观察到的事物中收获了很多。
There was this one guy in particular who I saw for almost, I think, like 10 months when I first moved to Sydney, who was a lovely person. He lived with his girlfriend. He was super interesting. But I think I started seeing him right after I'd had my heartbroken and I was really looking to him for a small dose of intimacy to almost wean me off of my last relationship without the commitment. Here's what I want. If you want to sleep with someone who was in an open relationship, you need to be really clear with yourself about a couple of things. Firstly, you have to be absolutely honest and clear with yourself that this person is not going to leave their partner for you. That is not going to happen. And if you pursue this connection thinking that you can
特别是有这样一个男人，我几乎和他交往了，我想，当我刚搬到悉尼时大概有10个月，他是一个可爱的人。他和他的女朋友住在一起。他非常有趣。但我想我开始和他交往正是在我心碎之后，我真的指望他能给我带来一小剂亲密感，几乎是帮我戒掉上一段关系，同时又不用承担承诺。以下是我想要的。如果你想和一个处于开放式关系中的人发生性关系，你需要对自己的一些事情有非常清晰的认识。首先，你必须对自己绝对诚实和清楚，这个人是不会为了你而离开他们的伴侣的。那是不会发生的。如果你追求这种联系，认为你可以
somehow change that or you do not respect their boundaries, you will only be disappointed. It's not fair to anyone. And you have to remember they have boundaries as well, so respect them. And you are just going to get hurt. You might really like this person. You might get all the woman fuzzies, but you have to remember that they are not going to leave their partner for you. At the end of the day, that's never going to happen. So are you prepared for that reality? Are you willing to accept that reality? Or should you maybe start looking elsewhere?
以某种方式改变这一点，或者你不尊重他们的边界，你只会感到失望。这对任何人都不公平。而且你必须记住他们也有界限，所以要尊重它们。而你只会受到伤害。你可能真的很喜欢这个人。你可能会产生所有的美好感觉，但你必须记住，他们不会为了你而离开他们的伴侣。归根结底，那是绝对不可能发生的。所以你准备好面对这个现实了吗？你愿意接受这个现实吗？或者你也许应该开始去别处看看？
Secondly, I would say, do not have sex with someone in an open relationship unless you are on the same page about your own ideas of monogamy. You know that right now you are not looking for a partnership or polyamory. if you are going into these situations, like I said, thinking that you want commitment or knowing that you are someone who is monogamous and you don't like the idea that this person might be sleeping with someone else, i.e. their partner, that's just going to be really triggering and upsetting for you. I would also say make sure you're aware of their boundaries and the boundaries that they've set in their relationship. For example, one of the ones I mentioned earlier is that
其次，我要说的是，除非你们对一夫一妻制有相同的看法，否则不要和处于开放式关系中的人发生性关系。你知道现在你并不是在寻找伴侣关系或多边恋。如果你进入这些情况，就像我说的，认为你想要承诺，或者明知自己是一个一夫一妻制的人，而且你讨厌这个人可能会和别人（即他们的伴侣）发生性关系的想法，那只会让你感到非常受触发和沮丧。我还想说，确保你知道他们的界限以及他们在关系中设定的界限。例如，我之前提到的其中一条是
they can't see you more than once a month. That is super fair. So it's not great to be hitting them up every week being like, what are you up to? Because A, you're going to be disappointed, but B, it's not showing respect for their boundaries. Sometimes you just don't know what they are, but it is really worth asking and knowing that you're on the same page so that you don't cause drama, first of all, but also you're not hurt and you're not left feeling disrespected. And finally, I would say, be really clear with yourself when it's time to walk away. If you start getting feelings for this person, it's time to walk away. It's, like I said, it's never going to work.
他们不能一个月见你超过一次。这非常公平。所以每周都去找他们问“你在干嘛呢”并不是什么明智的做法，因为 A，你会感到失望，但 B，这没有表现出对他们界限的尊重。有时你只是不知道这些界限是什么，但真的值得去问清楚，并确保你们在同一个频道上，这样首先你不会惹出抓马，其次你也不会受到伤害，不会感到不被尊重。最后，我要说的是，当到了该离开的时候，要对自己非常诚实。如果你开始对这个人产生感情，是时候离开了。正如我所说，这永远行不通。
If you're feeling like this intense jealousy towards their partner or you're like obsessed with looking up, you know, looking at them on social media or wondering what they're like when they're together, there's a natural level of curiosity and then there is an obsession. And once you're obsessed, you've got to realize that this relationship. relationship is not your relationship and maybe you should walk away. It's very complicated and it is, I think, a very new model in some of our minds for how to approach sex and dating, particularly in our 20s. But hopefully you're wise enough, you're mature enough, you're an adult and you
如果你对他们的伴侣感到这种强烈的嫉妒，或者你像着迷一样去搜寻，你知道的，在社交媒体上查看他们的动态，或者想知道他们在一起时是什么样子的，适度的自然好奇心是一回事，而着迷则是另一回事。一旦你着迷了，你就必须意识到这段关系并不是你的关系，也许你应该离开。这非常复杂，而且我认为，对于我们中的一些人来说，这是处理性与约会的一种非常崭新的模式，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候。但希望你足够聪明，足够成熟，你是一个成年人，并且
should be okay with navigating some of that complexity and have done the work on yourself to know when this arrangement is not right for you as the outsider, as the third. third party. I think we can learn a lot from this arrangement and this approach to a partnership, even if it's not personally for you. The conversations around boundaries that these couples have are often exceptional. And many couples who approach dating and companionship in an open manner have discussions about things like sex and issues and boundaries that most couples would not, because it needs to be on the table. They talk more about what trust means. to them what they need. They talk about the interaction between sex and their lives and what that
你应该能够应对这种复杂性，并在自己身上做过功课，从而知道这种安排何时不适合作为局外人、作为第三方的你。我认为我们可以从这种安排和对伴侣关系的这种方法中学到很多东西，即使它不适合你个人。这些情侣所进行的关于界限的对话通常非常出色。许多以开放态度对待约会和陪伴的情侣，会讨论大多数情侣不会讨论的诸如性问题和界限之类的事情，因为这些必须摆在台面上。他们更多地谈论信任对他们意味着什么，
means for their relationship. I think also some of the psychology behind it is really informative for us, for people who may be more monogamous. For example, understanding what personality traits kind of make us more receptive to this idea, discussions around sociosexuality. I think it's really important to examine our own approaches to uncommitted dating and uncommitted casual sex if you are someone who is looking for a partnership. If the idea of an open relationship makes you feel uncomfortable or icky or you're like, I would never do that. Maybe examine how you're approaching dating now because if you're only having casual relationships, those are technically, you know, open relationships. They're non-monogamous just without the commitment. So it's interesting that
他们需要什么。他们谈论性与他们生活之间的互动，以及这对于他们的关系意味着什么。我也认为其中的一些心理学对我们非常具有启发意义，特别是对于那些可能更偏向一夫一妻制的人来说。例如，理解什么样的个性特征会让我们更容易接受这种想法，围绕性社会学的讨论。如果你是一个正在寻找伴侣的人，我认为审视我们自己对不承诺的约会和不承诺的随性行为的态度真的很重要。如果开放式关系的念头让你感到不舒服、恶心，或者你觉得“我绝不会那样做”，也许可以审视一下你现在对待约会的方式，因为如果你只维持随意的关系，那些从技术上讲，你知道的，就是开放式关系。它们是非一夫一妻制的，只是没有承诺而已。
that we are naturally very opposed to opening a partnership to others, but very happy to open our situationships or our casual relationships to other people. They come with some of the same risks, but also some of the same triggers. So examining your perspective and your opinion on open relationships also allows you to examine your opinion and perspective on monogamous dating. I think additionally, it's really fascinating when we think about trust and acknowledging that people can have their own interests, needs and desires and sexual desires beyond the core relationship and that that relationship can still exist. It's just part of a broader
所以有趣的是，我们天生非常反对向其他人开放伴侣关系，但对于向其他人开放我们的无名分关系（situationships）或随性关系却非常高兴。它们带来了一些相同的风险，但也带来了一些相同的触发点。因此，审视你对开放式关系的看法和意见，也允许你审视自己对一夫一妻制约会的意见和看法。我认为此外，当我们思考信任并承认人们除了核心关系之外还可以有自己的兴趣、需求、欲望和性欲望，并且这种关系依然可以存在时，这真的非常迷人。这只是我们作为一个社会正在进行的更广泛的
discussion that we're having us as a society around whether the ideas that we've held for generations are really the correct ones to be having, whether they really do meet our needs as a society and as a generation. And a lot of people in their 20s are pushing back and not just their 20s of all ages. And that's just so amazing to me, whether you like this idea or you don't like this idea, I think it is really valuable to question the norm. And in this situation, monogamy is the norm. But with greater rates of divorce and greater rates of cheating, maybe it's worth examining whether that is the best way to go about dating and marriage and long-term partnerships and even raising children or creating families. So this has been so fascinating to me.
讨论的一部分，关于我们代代相传的观念是否真的是正确的观念，它们是否真的满足了我们作为社会和这一代人的需求。许多20多岁的人正在进行反抗，不仅仅是20多岁，各个年龄段都有。这对我来说太棒了，无论你喜欢这个想法还是不喜欢这个想法，我认为质疑常态真的很有价值。在这种情况下，一夫一妻制是常态。但随着离婚率和出轨率的升高，也许值得审视这是否是对待约会、婚姻、长期伴侣关系甚至是抚养孩子或创建家庭的最佳方式。所以这对我来说太迷人了。
And I hope that if you're someone who's curious and you didn't know much about this, that you have learned something as well. Feel free to share this episode with a friend. If it was a discussion you were having recently, maybe they could learn something from it as well. And as always, please feel free if you feel cool to do so to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. If you have an episode suggestion, if you have feedback, if you liked this episode, please reach out to me at that cycle. podcast on Instagram. You can see what episodes are coming up. You can vote on upcoming episodes or just be part of the community. It's always great to see more people over there. So I hope you give us a follow. If not, that's okay. But we will be back next week for another episode.
我希望如果你是一个好奇并且对这方面了解不多的人，你也学到了一些东西。请随时与朋友分享这集播客。如果这是你们最近一直在讨论的话题，也许他们也能从中学到一些东西。一如既往，如果你觉得可以的话，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你有节目建议、有反馈、或者喜欢这一集，请通过 Instagram 上的 that cycle. podcast 与我联系。你可以查看即将播出的剧集。你可以在即将播出的剧集上投票，或者只是成为社区的一部分。看到更多人来到这里总是很棒的。所以我希望你能关注我们。如果没有也没关系。但我们下周会带着另一集回归。
So until then, stay safe. And we will stay you soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me
直到那时，注意安全。我们很快会见到你。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了我们在奇怪的现代世界中展现出的精神坚韧、体能和培养复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。请收听“2%”。也就是在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO percent。“回看”播客。对于1979年来说，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84对我来说很大
I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚克斯·英格利斯。每一集我们挑选一个年份。剖析发生了什么。并试着和我们的朋友们一起弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的
Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild year I don't think There's a more important year for black people
同为喜剧演员的朋友们。以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔。关于80年代。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了
Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Hey what's good y'all You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回看”。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的“走难路”。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你必须这么做，请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“走难路”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。这动用了一大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰基尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困爱河”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“受困爱河”播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。